hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in the
nick of mccann ethics and the eudaimian
ethics the nick of mccain ethics has a
longer discussion of this the udemian
ethics which is
less often looked at as a complementary
but also somewhat shorter discussion of
this
we have a virtue that often doesn't get
talked much about
in terms of virtue ethics and even in
terms of aristotle
that is the virtue of magnificence and
aristotle
thinks that this is particularly
important it's important enough to treat
it
in the same section as another virtue
that's similar to it but on a smaller
scale liberality or generosity which
i've shot another video on
and like liberality it is concerned with
how and on what wealth or possessions or
you could think of it as capital gets
gets spent
it's not concerned with one other thing
that liberality is concerned that was
where you're getting your money from
that would actually be for aerosol
probably on this sort of scale something
more like
a concern of justice
why doesn't this get discussed i think
there's a few different reasons
one is that people say well you know
you looked at liberality magnificence is
just liberality on a big scale so if
you've seen liberality you've seen
magnificence just kind of extrapolate
from that
you know we're always pressed for time
so that i could see people doing that in
their classes
quite easily i think another more
important reason
is that we tend to be fairly egalitarian
in our teaching and our our research and
all that sort of stuff
in our society and magnificence is not a
an egalitarian virtue as such
meaning that not everybody can
participate in this
not everybody can cultivate this virtue
there on the other hand not everybody
can have these vices either
unless they're trying to
be magnificent when they simply don't
have the means to do so
see here's the thing in order to be
magnificent you have to have assertion
you have to have a certain amount of
what we might call capital whether
wealth or social capital or some other
type
and like i put here it's only possible
for those
who actually have wealth that can be
spent
or have connections maybe family
connections maybe professional
connections who have fame or i think
these days we would say celebrity of
some sort they can often
motivate people to get things done they
can organize
or some sort of um resources that that
are being provided to you because of
your family
and who you are and these things can
overlap in real societies they often do
tend to interfuse with each other
don't they now what this means is that
not everybody can be magnificent
so oftentimes i think people are less
interested in this because they say
well if not everybody can be involved in
this then maybe it's not that important
of a virtue
but it really is a critical virtue
and aristotle spends quite a bit of time
on it
and analyses on it because this is the
stuff that that
common social life the fabric
of the lives that we we live is formed
of
see for aristotle as for many other
theorists
it's not enough when we think about
common life
to think about the state
and just to say well we have the state
the government
its institutions they run everything and
private citizens don't make any sort of
uh
contribution to it or organizations you
could think of an organization
being composed of a bunch of people that
want to pull their resources to to to do
something that would be magnificent
what we would call civil society is
going to be to some degree
dependent on some people actually having
this virtue of magnificence
aristotle saw this in city-states in
greek city-states we often i think see
this
at the local level more than at the the
national level but you can think of
people who establish foundations as
perhaps
depending on you know where they fit in
on this chart exemplifying and
and putting into action the virtue of
magnificence
so let's think about this
what are the sorts of things what are
the sorts of occasions
where a person would display
magnificence and what this shows us if
we think about this
is that it's not just you know the
biggest
gigantic expenditures it can be family
things as well
a lot of families end up being important
in communities
and and that can
be a grounds for for exercising
magnificence let's start with the sort
of state
or or civilization or societal things
that aristotle himself talks about and
then they'll think about some some
modern day examples
so aristotle talks first off
about equipping triremes now what does
that mean
a trireme was the standard naval vessel
and in ancient greece you had a lot of
different city-states which would quite
often go to war with each other or with
non-greeks
and greece is um
it's a maritime country there were some
city-states that were
just landlocked but they were fairly
rare most of them were in the north
and you needed boats you needed
ships to transport your soldiers to
fight the other
navies basically for protection so
equipping a trireme
would be a fairly sizable expenditure
and it would be a way in which you help
out your
particular city-state your society
you are equipping them you are in effect
doing some of the defense budget
and you're doing it in a very particular
way this is the trireme that so and so
bought
he also talks about doing things like
this for temples
it's very important when you see that
sort of thing in greek writings
not to think of this as a purely private
matter the way many people tend to look
at religion these days
but as a public matter if there was a
temple to demeter
that's part of the city and so buying
some things for the temple
there might be some votive offerings
that a person makes because of you know
particular prayers i don't want to get
bogged down in greek religion too much
but they also might do things to you
know
spruce up the temple they might do
things to put on
a festival here we start getting into
some of the things patronage of the arts
that we might call it
but it's important to remember that a
lot of the arts festivals were also
religious festivals for the greeks
aristotle talks about equipping a chorus
and paying for a play to be put on and a
play was a very big production
it required you to have a playwright
actors
a chorus costumes a stage
um training for for a whole bunch of
time
so musicians as well most likely
and this meant that somebody was
actually shelling out money for that
he also talks about ways this can go can
go wrong
and you know end up being a matter of
vulgarity or lack of taste
but these are some standard examples he
he does give
quite a few other great examples that we
would want to think about
he also talks
about
sacrifices public buildings erecting a
public building
laying out the money for that
giving a banquet to the public that was
a lot more common
in in greek times than it was in ours
although you do find people
underwriting things this you know in our
day we talk about this as underwriting
or philanthropy or donations or things
like that
he also talks about weddings
now weddings you would say that's a
private a personal thing a family thing
well no because a wedding actually does
take place within a society
and that does in fact fit in
with you know the ways in which families
are connected to each other there's an
old saying when you marry a person you
actually marry their family
so weddings would be part of this and
you can do them in a tasteful way you
can do them in a
sort of mean spend you know pinch every
penny kind of way and you can do them in
a magnificent way
people talk about this sort of stuff
believe me when people go to a wedding
and they get served to really you know
they they bring a good gift and they get
served a really cheap plate
and the dj's no good and the band is no
good they kind of feel like somebody was
was uh being mean or stingy
he also talks about welcoming foreign
guests celebrating their departure
not such a such a big issue for us
complementary interchange of presence
this um requires a little bit of
explanation for the greeks
something that was called guest
friendship xenia
was very important families that were
long established would have connections
with each other to families in
other city-states and if
i came to your city state and i'm a
guest friend i would be expected to give
you a gift and you would be expected to
give me a gift in return
and you can do that these are these
would not just be very small
gifts too these would be you know fairly
big ticket items
and why would you be doing this well
to show something good to show something
fine we'll get to that in a moment
he also talks about one other thing
that's really interesting and this is
one thing that i think a lot of us can
connect to
he talks about furnishing houses
the magnificent person furnishes his or
her
house her dwelling and i think we can
see this with with workplaces with those
who actually
you know own their own business or
things like that
there's going to be a focus on quality
on having things that convey
a certain class we might say now you
know
some people may see this as very
classist or anti-egalitarian or anything
like that i'm just explaining what
aristotle actually says here
there probably is an aspect of that but
aristotle thinks that there is
you know a distinction there's the
higher the noble the better
the the fine toka is what what the
greeks would call it and then you know
going down there's
the ignoble the base the dishonorable um
the cheap the tawdry and you want to
avoid that and you want to have the
nicer
things aristotle actually at this point
gets quite specific and says
the magnificent person in decorating
their house is going to prefer a few
nice things that are really lasting as
opposed to
you know other things now let's talk
we've got a lot of examples there and
you can think of
i think a lot of contemporary examples
you know forms of philanthropy that
people engage in
giving to colleges giving to foundations
donating things to the local fire
department but i don't want to get
too bogged down in those we could go on
to those examples all day long
let's talk about the basic structure of
this habit
that the virtue consists in
so the magnificent person like any
virtuous person for aristotle there's a
lot of rights
and it has to do not with
taking but with giving with what they're
spending their money on
they spend the right amount of money or
resources or whatever you you know
you're talking about whatever kind of
capital
on the right things so it's not just
enough to spend a medium amount
that you're actually spending a fairly
large amount
but you spend it on the right things for
the right occasions
not just anytime out of the blue the
magnificent person
isn't the person who tries to make an
occasion they'll find enough occasions
enough things come up in social life
where you can spend some money and
accomplish something
noble and good and memorable that you
don't have to actually manufacture
occasions all of this has to do with
something that in greek is the
suitable the that which is befitting
that which is proportionate to what it
is that you're trying to accomplish
now what is going through the mind
and through the heart of the magnificent
person
when they're engaged in giving or even
later on when they're looking
back at what they've accomplished and
what they've spent when they
open up the checkbook and they look at
the building they say
this is a big donation their purpose is
accomplishing
something noble something
fine something elevated
aristotle says this goes beyond the
realm of the merely necessary
and starts getting towards what is more
distinctively human
what elevates us what what takes us out
of the realm
of just the purely day-to-day getting by
and gives us something that we can
admire something we can look up to
something that we can say
wow yeah that's really that's really
something worthwhile i want to i want to
be involved in that i want to emulate it
i am
proud of that you could think of that as
a person is willing to
shell out money for something not just
that they can be proud of
but other people who are involved in it
can be proud of as well
that's a very important component i
think
the the person who is magnificent
also like aristotle says spends gladly
and spends generously
they feel pleasure in spending that
money
you know that's an important point there
that really separates people
out not everybody who's who's you know
hit up to make a donation spends
generously
gladly with pleasure a lot of people do
it very grudgingly
and that takes them over to this side
the vice of of meanness
now these people actually do sometimes
spend
it's not as if they don't spend at all
but
they spend less than is actually right
for the occasion
they're always trying to hold on to
every little bit of resources that they
have
and there could be a lot of reasons for
this
we're not going to dwell on those in
part because aristotle doesn't i think
that could be something you can think of
on your own
they're focused constantly on counting
the costs
they pay attention to the cost much more
than the magnificent person does
it's not as if the magnificent person
just writes blank checks
but the magnificent person is less
focused on the value of the money and
more on the value of what the money can
buy what the money can make happen
only if it's spent only if it's spent on
the right things
this person is more focused on the money
they're more focused on what am i
actually going to get back from this
what am i shelling this out for
and they try to think of everything in
terms of dollars and they're always
trying to
try to lower costs trying to conserve
costs try to be more efficient trying to
find ways to say no we don't really need
that
think of a wedding for example you know
one of the things a groom is groom's
family is traditionally supposed to
provide
is the beer liquor wine at the reception
if it's not a dry wedding and the band
or the dj
there's a lot of ways you could try to
cut costs with that right
is it going to be an open bar or a cash
bar the generous person is going to be
more inclined to say
let's do an open bar unless of course
they're dealing with people who are
total drunks right
the uh mean person is going to be more
inclined to say
yeah let's do cash bar i don't want to
really pay for
for all these people it's enough that
i'm actually bringing the stuff here
um choice between spending a little bit
more on a band and having a dj
the magnificent person is going to shell
out for the band
because it's more fun authentic you know
lively social experience whereas the dj
man not so much so this person is
focused on counting and cutting the cost
they're pained they feel pain when they
spend
they feel less pain when they spend less
that's why they're trying to spend less
they think that they're spending more
this is a really interesting observation
that aristotle makes
when they look at what they're spending
if their their their viewpoint is
actually skewed
they think that they're spending the
right amount
that's why they're vicious there's a
certain kind of blindness that goes with
that
they think that they're spending more
than they ought to that other people are
like
drawing things out of them and they
become quite miserable
and irritable with other people as as a
result
let's look now at the other extreme so
there are some people who are perfectly
willing to spend
you know all sorts of money all sorts of
capital all sorts of things just
open up the the purse you know or the
pocketbook and just let's go
but it might not be for the right uh
things and it might not be on the right
occasion
there are ways to to spend and to give
people things that are kind of vulgar
that are kind of low class
it's interesting the term that we're
translating here is lack of taste
literally means not being able to
find not just the suitable but the
noble the word is is uh
you know literally from opera
and cologne not being able to find your
way to the
the fine or the honorable or the noble
that which is elevated the
person over here is willing to spend
as much as they want oftentimes they
spend beyond what is right
and they spend it on the wrong things
sometimes they actually
give short shrift to the right things
and they'll spend it on on
you know things that are more visible
things that are easier to appeal to
a larger crowd you know you could think
for example of
oprah you know everybody reaching under
their chair
oh you've all got a car um
aristotle would see that as vulgar he
would see that as
as going beyond good taste
as just sort of leveling everything out
and going for the easy
you know grip at everybody's emotions
kind of moment
and that that comes from the fact that
these people want to be big shots
they want to feel like they're the ones
shelling everything out they want to be
the center of attention
they want other people to look at them
they want to feel
as if they are really
making things happen really rich admired
and this is not a very good strategy for
doing that is it
because as soon as the money's gone
people who are there with you just
because you're you're paying out for
them you know if you have an entourage
as soon as that money's gone they're
gone they don't really care about you
they're not really your friends they
don't really admire you because you're
not spending your money to do the right
things with your money
you're not spending it on things that
are really beneficial
lasting quality
you're just spending it on you know
making everything have a
a good time you know for for everybody
so long as it can hold out
this person feels pleasure in spending
but they don't feel pleasure in a
discriminate kind of way
aristotle talks about the magnificent
person
as being discriminate as being
able to figure out what the
right amount is what the befitting is
this person over here lacks a sense of
the befitting
this person over here lacks it in a very
different way
this person is willing to spend but they
don't have a good sense of what they
ought to be spending on and they're
probably not going to get good advice
from other people because people in fact
do like it when you spend money on them
and on causes that they like the person
over here
doesn't have a good sense of what's
befitting they
they don't see that if they let go if
they're a little bit more
generous with their their money their
resources
things would actually turn out better
for them
the person here in the middle has a
habit
has a a aspect of their character that
is built up over
time in discerning what the right amount
is
what the right occasions are what the
right purpose is what we want to spend
this money on
they will ask themselves that question
whereas this person
will probably say yeah i really don't
want to spend the money or you want me
to spend the money on that and this
person will say yeah okay
whatever just let me give you a blank
check
you just tell me whatever you want to
spend it on you're going to have my name
on it right
so you see that these are actually
habits that people build over time
now the one thing i want to close with
when we're thinking about virtues and
vices particularly when we're thinking
about virtues that can't be practiced by
everybody
one of the things that i think we want
to devote some thought to
is thinking about how do we actually
cultivate these
how would you and i'm going to just
leave this as a challenge
how would you prepare people who right
now don't have a lot of means think
about college students for example
who don't have a lot of means to be
magnificent
rather than to be mean or to be
vulgar well you know maybe the
decoration thing is one way to get
get in at this maybe volunteering is
another way to think of it
maybe um being trained in the virtue of
liberality or generosity
is in fact some sort of bridge to
training for this
larger scale virtue of magnificence
but those are just sort of beginning
points i'm going to leave
off with with that and you can reflect
on it